pour des enfants immigrés dans l'école
depuis deux ans dans l'académie d'aix
marseille
une expérience va précisément dans ce
sens bernard marck et à marseille on
appelle ça le frais vallon là où naguère
couler les sources on a coulé du béton
8000 habitants 60 % d'immigrés 12 et
nîmes nationalité déracinement chômage
délinquance aussi pour la police le
frais vallon est un point chaud pas de
vie de quartier ni de relations de
voisinage seul lieu de rencontre le
groupe scolaire alors scellé par qui a
pris en charge la création des liens
indispensables méthode d'abord banaliser
le fait qu'un élève parle par exemple
arabe et qu'ils appartiennent à une
culture autre dans les classes
maternelles ça peut commencer par une
chanson
il serait prétentieux d'apprendre la
culture sur la naissance est née par on
ne peut pas la prendre mais ils ont
l'ambition serait de susciter des
questions positive une reconnaissance
positive de l'autre et une acceptation
comme ça on les enfants d'origine
étrangère ne connaissez pas quelquefois
une même leur civilisation alors sont
les a sensibilisés à la civilisation et
les autres ont découvert que ces
étrangers et bien avec quelque chose ce
thème porte homme derrière avec l'aide
des enseignants étrangers à la grande
école on peut aller plus loin quelques
rudiments de langue cette fois c'est
l'italien puis à travers un fait commun
de civilisation chacun affirmera sa
personnalité sa peine
le carnaval isralien cd guizot si on
fait la fête ou en italie et chad existe
importance de l'immigration a donc
conduit l'école unificatrice de jules
ferry à reconnaître la différence en la
valorisant dans sa dimension culturelle
mais ce n'est encore qu'une expérience
ponctuelle dans l'académie d'aix
marseille
c'est vraiment la vocation par
excellence des maîtres parce que ça
passe par la connaissance précisément de
ces différentes ethnies et nous avons de
fonder avec le centre de documentation
un groupe de recherche sur les
communautés ethniques en provence qui
réunit des membres de ces diverses
communautés pour discuter sur les
meilleures façons de lutter parle
cette connaissance réciproque contre les
phénomènes de racisme ambiant
ils sont nés à marseille sont
exclusivement francophone ils apprennent
l'arabe aux frais vallon il y a donc
aussi des cours spéciaux pour ceux qui
veulent retrouver la langue de leurs
parents et des parents en voici
quelques-uns pour eux aussi l'école joue
son rôle de lieu de rencontre ils y sont
accueillis ils discutent de l'expérience
pédagogique en cours bref ils
communiquent et se connaissent mieux ici
secret peut-être grâce à l'école au sein
d'une collectivité artificielle récente
et disparates un tissu social nouveau
une toute dernière nouvelle en politique
à l'élection cantonale partielle de
lille centre
madame denise ce gars est élu au
deuxième tour avec plus de 70% des voix
elle succède à son mari récemment décédé
médecine